a lawsuit filed just last night is
drawing new attention to a
cancer-causing chemical called ethylene
oxide it's used to sterilize about half
of all US medical equipment five former
educators who worked at the same high
school near Chicago blamed their
illnesses on a sterilizing plant that
used the chemical consumer investigative
correspondent anna warner is with us to
talk more about why there is this
connection or why these women think that
there's a link right well Jericka that
school is about three-quarters of a mile
from the plant and the men women believe
that plant gave them cancer your doctors
have told you that they can't cure you
it is not curable
Margaret s keyword Maness is talking
about her terminal blood cancer - Lee
next Christmas and you don't know do you
I told her Dumanis is one of five women
who all worked at Hinsdale South High
School and all later developed cancer
well you just give me a hand raised of
who has breast cancer okay and your
cancer is Waldenstrom's form of lymphoma
the reason for their cancers they say a
nearby plant they never even knew was
there for over 30 years company stereo
genex sterilized medical equipment in
this building using a gas called
ethylene oxide a chemical known to cause
cancer
unknown to residents the plant released
thousands of pounds of that invisible
gas into the surrounding neighborhoods
for decades former teacher peg Vall deck
so many of us taught with our windows
wide open in the spring in the fall she
and former educators earned Manas Rose
Kepler Carole 2fo and Jeanne de Brock
all say had you ever heard of ethylene
oxide no what they did notice over the
years they say was the number of their
former colleagues who also came down
with cancer there were five in the wing
that I worked in in my department the
six six of us and we used to talk about
don't drink the water here's yeah
because we you know we needed a reason a
reason for why people were sick ethylene
oxide is used in medical sterilizing
plants and chemical plants around the
country experts have known for decades
that the toxic gas could be linked to
cancers including breast and blood
cancers but it wasn't until last year
that residents in nearly 20 communities
around the country found out that by a
new EPA analysis their cancer risk from
exposure to the chemical might now be
higher the Sturridge annex plant in
Willowbrook less than a mile from the
high school became a flashpoint for
protests it brought awareness and anger
this is a death sentence that you're
passing on to all of us I am as mad as
can be is that why you're speaking out
yes
yes I'm worried about the people that do
not know they need to know your health
is at risk you know it's not only a
local issue it's a national issue and
people are unknowingly being exposed
without having to be Sturridge NX now
faces multiple lawsuits but told us in a
statement
it's confident that it is not
responsible for causing cancers the
company says it has consistently
complied with and outperformed
applicable regulations but lawyer Shawn
Collins who represents the five women
insists the company knew there were
risks they were told he points to this
letter from the Illinois EPA to the
plants former owners in 1984 warning
that when it's sterilizers were built
ethylene oxide emissions would be
several magnitudes higher than desirable
I've never seen a situation where before
a company even opened its doors it was
told if you do what you say you want to
do you're really risking the health of
your neighbors and then it went ahead
and did it anyway is it possible in your
mind that maybe they thought they were
being protective as a
Sturridge annex closed its Willowbrook
plant in September
citing problems with a lease but
nationwide more than 100 sterilizing
plants still use ethylene oxide there
has to be another way to clean medical
equipment rather than poisoning the rest
of us in the United States or wherever
they're doing it medical device
manufacturers disagree with that idea
their association advil med told us that
medical sterilization facilities need to
remain open in order to avoid what they
call a potentially catastrophic shortage
of critical medical devices sterilized
through this irreplaceable process both
that group and the FDA say that if more
sterilizing plants shut down right now
there'd be a shortage of some critical
medical devices and the EPA is working
on a new emission standard for the
chemical for next year meanwhile some of
the other communities possibly at higher
risk are now looking at this issue so
you have 100 sterilizing plants in this
country are there alternatives so there
are alternatives although that group
Advan med maintains that those
alternatives don't necessarily work for
all medical devices they say there are
certain things you need this for but I
think the hunt is on for alternatives
and the FDA is also encouraging
companies to develop alternatives really
great reporting in and thank you very
much
you